I have such a great documentary
recommendation today and I had forgotten
because Louis recommended this to me so
long ago and I finally got to it because
my netflix queue is overflowing it's
called the two escobars and it was
actually produced by the symbolist
brothers whose dad works with my mom at
Smith College in Northampton
Massachusetts there you go uh and it
deals with two Colombian Escobar's the
the more well known as Pablo Escobar of
one of the arguably the most successful
in richest drug kingpin in history if
you look at uh the dollar value of the
drugs that he was trafficking absolutely
stunning and another Colombian Escobar
Andres Escobar a soccer player and I
remember this i was i was ten years old
at the time of the 1994 world cup and i
remember Andres Escobar scoring an own
goal scoring a goal against his own team
and not that long after he was killed in
Colombia and I I remember this vividly
when I was 10 or 11 years old the
documentary Louis which I know you've
seen is so well produced and it is
absolutely both horrifying and
incredibly compelling yeah it's um it's
the best 34-30 I've seen I wasn't
originally a 34-30 right right but uh
it's a fascinating look into that
country at the time into the hole
Escobar cartel thing into soccer and
also into the connection between Pablo
Escobar and his funding of soccer yes Oh
yet the funding of soccer in general is
a major theme in this and um he yes oh
yeah he had a hand in it bleed
incredibly well produced it is called
the two escobars it's on amazon it's on
netflix and you can stream it directly
from david pakman.com slash
recommendations where you can also see
my full list of film and book
recommendations gamefly is sort of like
netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low
use price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at gamefly offer.com /
TDPS the games are shipped directly to
you with return envelopes included
there's no contracts and you can rent
games through the mobile app get the
free 30-day trial for the david pakman
show audience and support our show by
going to gamefly offer.com slash TDP s